[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Bank robberies,
military compounds, and spies--
that's what you might
think of when it
comes to data center security.
And to be honest,
you're not too far off.
But how exactly
does Google reliably
secure its data centers?
It all starts with six layers,
also known as Defense in Depth.
Layers become progressively more
protected with access checks
as you move to the core
of the data center.
Layers one and two involve
property boundaries,
vehicle crash barriers,
fences with motion detection,
guard kiosks, and
thermal cameras.
Layer three gives you
access to the secure lobby,
where you get your irises
scanned, and will find
the general office area where
hardware and data center
operations teams work.
You're now in the
data center building.
Badge checks exist
at every entry point,
and only one person can go
through a door at a time.
As you move to
layer four, you'll
find operational rooms, like the
core network room and security
operations center, which
contains a highly trained staff
that monitors all
aspects of security
and can keep a level
head at all times.
Next is layer five,
the data center floor.
Less than 1% of Googlers
ever get to set foot here.
This is where data lives.
In order to advance, you
have to walk through a circle
lock, a big glass tube that
lets only one person enter
at a time.
Here, you get your
credentials checked
and your irises scanned.
This is a form of
dual-factor authentication.
You must present two forms of
identification-- in this case,
a badge and biometric data--
to validate an
individual's identity.
Layer six is disk erase,
where retiring hard drives
get their data wiped and reused
or shredded and recycled.
Only those with
special access can
enter the disk erase
room and retrieve drives
through a secure
two-way locker system.
In order to exit
layers five and six,
you're required to go
through full metal detection
under the supervision
of a staff member.
But what about protecting
from the outside?
We're talking asteroids,
electromagnetic pulses, fires,
pandemics, and zombies.
We run dozens of
drills a year, engaging
unannounced skilled adversaries
to try to get past controls.
After every testing
attempt, we always
evaluate our
performance to ensure
the strength of our
security controls
and iterate controls, as needed.
Now, that's what you call
a culture of security.
If you want to learn more, check
out cloud.google.com/security.
[MUSIC PLAYING]